ونحييكم مشاهدينا الى نقاش الملف الثاني
هدوء حذر على خط الحدود الايرانيه
الافغانيه وعوده لفتح الحدود ولحركه
العبور وذلك بعد يومين من الاشتباكات
والاتهامات المتبادله بين ايران وحركه
طالبان الافغانيه الجانبان تبادل
الاتهامات بالمبادرة باطلاق النار على
الحدود ما تسبب بمقتل جنديين من جنود قوات
حرس الحدود الايرانيه وفق وكاله الانباء
الايرانيه لترد حركه طالبان اتهام طهران
بتاجيج الاشتباكات على الحدود مع الاشاره
الى ان اختلاق اعذار النيشان حرب ليس في
مصلحه احد كما صعد الطالبان من لهجتها مع
طهران قائله انهم اذا شاؤوا او عزموا
ليحتلوا ايران خلال 24 ساعه سيفعلها
حسابات مقربه من طالبان كانت قد نشرت
مقاطعها تظهر اصطفافا لعشرات الجنود مع
مركبات ومدرعات على الحدود مع ايران الخ
لافات بين ايران وطالبان اشتدت في الايام
الاخيره حول حصص توزيع مياه نهر هلماند
بعد بناء سد اثر على تدفق المياه الى
ايران التي تعاني جفافا شديدا لكن الابعاد
العميقه للتوتر تتدفق ربما من نهر سياسي
اخر
الحدود المشتركه بين ايران وافغانستان
تبدا من مضيق ذو الفقار حيث المثلث
الحدودي بين ايران وافغانستان
وتركمانستان في الشمال تستمر الحدود حتى
جبل مالك سياح حيث المثلث الحدودي بين
ايران وافغانستان وباكستان في الجنوب
بمسافه
945 كم
جذور الخلاف بين ايران وافغانستان تعود
الى عده عقود وحول حصص البلدين من نهرها
المد
ذاك النهر الذي ينبع من جباله هندوكوش
شمال شرقي افغانستان يجري لمسافه اكثر من
الف كيلو متر حتى بلوغ بحيرتها هامون عند
الحدود بين البلدين
يعد نهرها المند اهم مصدر للماء في
البلدين والشريان اساسيا لمحافظه السيستان
ايران تقول ان افغانستان رفضت توفير حصه
ايران المائيه خلال سنوات الماضيه من خلال
بناء سد كاجاكي ثم سد كما الخان حيث غيرت
مجرى نهرها المند بطريقه لا تسمح للمياه
بالدخول حتى في حال الفيضان
هناك مع ضيوفنا من طهران محمد صالح
صادقيان المحلله السياسي اهلا بك صادقيان
ومن كابول عبد الجبار بهير رئيس المركز
الافغاني للاعلام والدراسات اهلا بكم
ضيفاي الكريمين واسمحالي ان ابدا من طهران
معك سيد صادقيان تعلم حضرتك بان الخلاف
على توزيع المياه او على توزيع حصص المياه
بين افغانستان وايران ليس بالموضوع الجديد
يعني جذورهم ممتده لعقود ولكن من يتحمل
مسؤوليه التصعيد الذي اودى بحياه البعض
على الحدود الافغانيه الايرانيه في هذه
الفتره بالتحديد
مساء الخير لك ولضيفك وللمشاهدين هذا صحيح
جدا ان هذه يعني هذا السد الذي بني على
نهر علما هو بني
بتعاون من قبل ايران والحكومه الافغانيه
وبالتالي هناك اتفاقيه لتقسيم المياه
ولتقسيم الضرر فيما اذا جفت المياه او قلل
قله المياه في في هذا الساده وفي نهر
المندوب وبالتالي الان نحن نواجه مشكله
هذه المشكله لا تخص الايرانيين
ايضا لانه هناك شحه في المياه هو حاجه
البلدين والمنطقتين المحاذيتين للحدود
المشتركه للمياه
اقليم سيسان
يفتقد للمياه المورد الوحيد للمياه هو نهر
هيلمند او ما ياتي من نهر علما وهناك في
الطرف الاخر في المناطق الافغانيه ايضا
هناك مشكله في المياه لكن انا اعتقد بان
الحوار الذي تم بين ايران وبين افغانستان
وتحديدا مع الحكومه الطالبان في كابول
اعتقد بان الامور تسير باتجاه الحل لكن
يجب ان تكون هناك يكون هناك نوع من تعزيز
الثقه بالشكل الذي لا يؤدد الى تجديد
نحن كذلك
هو في الواقع المتابع للمحادثات يعتقد بان
هناك حلول حقيقيه وتعلم حضرتك بانه حتى
فتره حكومه اشرف غني كانت هناك بين الجانب
الايراني والجانب الافغاني كانت هناك
محادثات حول هذا الموضوع ولكن ان يندلع
التصعيد ونكون امام الشبكات استاذ عبد
الجبار هل تتحمل افغانستان مسؤوليتها في
بناء ليس سد وانما سد ثاني كذلك كان هناك
سد كجكي وسطنا نتحدث كذلك عن كمال خان
التصريحات الايرانيه تقول بان هناك تعمد
افغاني بحرمان المناطق الشماليه الايرانيه
من حصتها في المياه
بطبيعه الحال يعني لاول مره ايران تواجه
رساله واضحه من الحكومه الافغانيه انها
لابد ان تجلس الى الواقع الميداني وان
تجلس كذلك الى ما هو المتفق بين الجانبين
اتفاقيه 1973 هي واضحه ومنذ تسعيد وهو ليس
الان يعني منذ
تصعيد المواقف بين ايران والحكومه
الافغانيه الحاليه منذ اكثر من سنه كان
اول او اولى طلبات ايرانيه تجاه طالبان او
الحكومه الجديده في افغانستان هو الموافقه
على المياه وكذلك كان يعتبر
لكن
هذا الموضوع حدده اتفاق 1973 هذا الاتفاق
يطالب افغانستان بان تمد الجانب الايراني
بما مقداره 820 مليون متر مكعب من المياه
كل عام
ايران تقول بانه لم يصلها الا عشر تقريب
او حتى اقل هذه الكميه ان كنا نتحدث عن
هذا الاتفاق فتصريحات الايرانيه تقول بان
افغانستان هي التي لم تلتزم بهذا المعاهده
يعني يعني هو هذا هو يعني
اساس الموضوع او الهدف الاساسي
والمطالبه الافغانيه لماذا ايران تهرب من
الجلوس الى طاوله المفاوضات حول هذه
الاتفاقيه هي واضحه وليس كما اشرت
يعني عفوا كما اشرت الى الى تفاصيل هذه
الاتفاقيه ايران ومنذ اربعين سنه ومنذ
عشرين سنه بالذات كان هناك المياه
ذهبت الى ايران مياه اكثر من ما هو المتفق
عليه هو يعني حوالي
860 مليون متر مكعب في في سنه وانما كان
هناك لا احد يطالب ايران لماذا تمشي كل
هذه المياه هكذا هباء منثوره من اراضي
افغانيه
والايران لماذا لا تجلس على يعني لماذا لا
تناقش كان الموقف الافغاني واضحا نناقش
نعم كان هناك يعني حدود واضحه سواء على
الثواني او الايام او يعني ما هي الظروف
التي تمشي المياه من افغانستان الى كل هذه
هي بكل تفاصيلها هي حوالي يعني اربع صفحات
كل هذه اتفاقيه واضحه
اني افغانستان لا تجلس مع افغانستان خليني
انقل هذا التساؤل الضيفي من طهران استاذ
صادقيان هل تتهرب طهران من الجلوس من
مفاوضات قادره ان تحل المساله او انا
طهران كما يقول الجانب الافغاني هي تحاول
ايجاد اعذار لشني حرب هكذا تتحدث
افغانستان الرسميه
على العكس بذلك ايران دخلت في حوارات مع
حكومه كابول وتحديدا السفير الايراني في
كابول كاظم القطبي وهو لديه صلاحيات كبيره
في
الحوار مع الحكومه الافغانيه حكومه
الطالبان في كابول وهناك عده اجتماعات
عقدت بين الجانبين وانا اعتقد بان حتى
حكومه كابل على حسب المعلومات التي
امتلكها حكومه كابل
متجاوبه مع والايرانيون ايضا يعني لا توجد
هناك خلافات في المفاوضات لكن هناك في
التنفيذ هذا في التنفيذ
الجهه التي تسيطر على السد هي ليست الجهه
متعاونه بشكل جيد مع حكومه الطالبان في
كابول وبالتالي ربما هناك اجنحه واتجاهات
معينه
في اطار حكومه الطالبان ولذلك في التنفيذ
وليس هناك عدد
في التنفيذ فقط لما وصلنا الى حدود
الاشتباكات المسلحه هذه الشبكات المسلحه
يقول البعض بانها نتاج لتصريحات اشعلت
فتيل ازمه حقيقيه هذه التصريحات نطق بها
مسؤولون فان كنا نتحدث عن مفاوضات ان كنا
نتحدث عن محادثات جاريه لما كانت تمت هكذا
اشتباكات اليس كذلك
دعيني اشير الى نقطه في غايه الاهميه
ويعني
ربما هناك يعني سوء فهم في ربط الاشتباكات
التي حدثت قبل يومين في اقليم نيمروز
قضيه المياه هذين القضيتين والموضوعين
منفصلين بشكل كامل هذه الاشتباكات التي
الاشتباكات التي حدثت هي ليست الاولى من
نوعها وبالتالي على الحدود الايرانيه
الافغانيه المشتركه هناك بعض المشاكل هذه
المشاكل يسببها كثير من القضايا هناك
تجاره البشر هناك تهريب بالبضائع هناك
الكثير من
المهربين يعملون على هذه النقطه الحدوديه
وهناك ايضا جماعات انفصاليه مسلحه ايرانيه
تعمل بعضها في الحدود الافغانيه هل هناك
مشاكل من هذا النوع وهي التي حدثت يعني
هذه الاشتراكات حدثت في هذا الاطار
مفهوم كلام حضرتك ولكن تفضل تفضل اكمل
لكن بشكل عام هذه الاشتباكات التي حدثت
كانت محدوده
وتم
تسويتها وتم
والان الحدود نقطه الحدود نقطه الصفر على
الحدود الايرانيه الافغانيه هي مستتبه لا
توجد هناك اي مشاكل وحتى سمعت بان
الحدود تفتح بين حين واخر لنقل البضائع
التي تحتاجها افغانستان وهذا الامر يبدو
قد انتهى لكن بعض الاوساط هناك تريد
تضخيم هذا الحدث لكن حسب المعلومات التي
يمتلكها هناك تجاوب من حكومه الطالبان في
كابول مع الجهات الايرانيه واعتقد بان
الامر قد سوي بشكل نهائي في هذه
الاشتباكات التي حدثت قبل يومين حضرتك
تتحدث عن طريق الحرير الذي تم اغلاقه
لفتره وفيما بعد تم فتحه من جديد سيد عبد
الجبار المواضيع منفصله عن بعضها البعض
كما تفضل بالاشاره الاستاذ صادقين لانه في
الواقع ما روج له الاعلام في الجهتين وما
قراناه ما وصلنا كذلك عن الاعلام الايراني
وكذلك عما
تحدثت به بعض الوكالات الافغانيه بانه
هناك ترابط في الاحداث هناك استفزاز على
مستوى الحدود بالربط مع موضوع قضيه المياه
احدهم حتى قال بانه نحن يعني من حركه
طالبان ان كانت تختلق ايران الاعذار لشن
حرف فنحن قادرون على الهجوم قادرون حتى
على شان هذه الحرب انفسنا استاذ عبد
الجبار ما رايك حضرتك في هذه النقطه
بطبيعه الحال يعني انا
لعل المعلومات
الميدانيه في افغانستان كان الاشتباكات
التي وقعت قبل يومين كان رئيس الجيش
الاركان الايراني يحاور رئيس الجيش
الاركان الافغاني في كابول ووقع
الاشتباكات وكان النقطه الاساسيه هي لماذا
التوتر حول المياه لا يحل عن طريق يعني كل
ما تريده الحكومه الافغانيه ايران كان
بهذه الاشتباكات او بهذه بهذا التصحيح
الاشتباكات في هذه الفتره الزمنيه كان
هناك اهم اهداف لايران ان بلبله الوضع في
افغانستان وكذلك كانت تريد ان ان تقدم ان
افغانستان
الحكومه الافغانيه على الاقل يعني هي
مستهدفه من من عده من عده الجهات الاجنبيه
وكذلك الغربيه الامريكيه وكذلك يعني دول
الجوار انها انها لا تريد ان تتعامل مع
دول الجوار لا تريد ان تتعامل بحسن او ان
تتعامل يعني بسياسه وانما هي يعني هي ضرر
على تواجدها ضرر على على مصالح في المنطقه
الحكومه الافغانيه كانت من بدايه الامر
تؤكد على ان ان الحوار هو الحل الوحيد
وانما الجانب الايراني بعد ان ادرك ان
الحكومه الافغانيه جاده في ان ان اتفاقيه
هي الاساس الجانب الايراني لحد الان لم لم
يعني لم تصرح على ان الاتفاقيه نعم صرحت
ان هناك اتفاقيه لكن دائما وابدا ان تؤكد
على ان حق المياه لايران بدون تفاصيل كان
هناك طلبات غير غير يعني لا تمشي مع سياده
البلد كان الطلب مثلا مره ان يكون هناك
وقتا ايرانيا تذهب وتزور المياه في
افغانستان وتزور كذلك المناطق الحساسه
المناطق العسكريه التي تحيط هذه السدود
ستكمال خان وست كجاكي الحكومه الافغانيه
رفضت بكل بكل صراحه وبكل وضوح انها لا لا
افهم
وانما تتعامل كدوله مستقله افغانيه ان
تجلس الى طاوله هذه هو ان ندرس يعني دراسه
فنيه وليست دراسه يعني دراسه
الجلوس ايران على طويله المفاوضات ولكن
لافهم من حضرتك المطالب الافغانيه طالما
افغانستان ترى بانه ايران هي المقصره هي
التي منعت او هي التي تحاول اختلاق اعذار
لشن حرب
لماذا افغانستان اتت منها تصريحات عن حركه
طالبان تصاعد اكثر فاكثر هناك من قال في
داخل حركه طالبان لا تختبر صبرنا ولا
تختبر قوتنا ونحن قادرون حتى على الدخول
وعلى السيطره على ايران في غضون 24 ساعه
طبعا يعني تصريح قد تكون فيه مبالغه ولكن
تصريح يوجه بالتصعيد
بطبيعه الحال اول تصريحات كان تصريحات
الاستستازيه لرئيس الايراني الذي هدد كيان
الحكومه الافغانيه وكذلك حدد السياده
الافغانيه تصريحات التي جاءت نعم كان هناك
قيادات كان هناك افراد من حركه الطالبان
ومن الحكومه الافغانيه لهم تصريحات مبين
خان الذي قدم جالون من الماء كسخريه وكذلك
هناك يعني قيادات اخرى التي صرحوا خراسان
الذي حميد خراسان الذي احد المسؤولين في
في جنوب شرق افغانستان صرح انه بامكانه ان
يسيطر على ان تحتل او ان يسيطر على الطحان
في 24 ساعه كل هذه تصريحات فرديه وانما
الموقف الافغاني منذ منذ التسعيد ومنذ
الحوار بين افغانستان وبين ايران حول
المياه كان يعني
موقفا موقفا لينا او موقفا يعني كان كان
تؤكد دائما يعني رئيس الوزراء الافغاني
كان اول موقف لرئيس الوزراء الافغاني ثم
كان تصريحات المتحدث باسم الحكومه
الافغانيه انها لا تريد التصعيد مع ايران
سواء مع اي دوله
يعني في بجوار وانما تريد التعامل
بالمعامل المحترم بعد ذلك كان هناك
تصريحات لمسؤولين الايران اليوم كان
التصريحات لبعض المسؤولين الايران انها لا
تريد ان التسعيد ليس في صالح لا ايران ولا
افغانستان وانما وان كنت نتحدث
الجانب الايراني وليس من جانب الافغاني في
اطار التصعيد الكلامي مع هذه الاشتباكات
ولكن البعض يتخوف استاذ صادقيان من ان
تتوسع رقعه هذه الاشتباكات استمعت الى
ضيفي هو ربطه في الواقع ما حدث على الحدود
من اشتباكات مع ازمه المياه حضرتك طبعا
ترى عكس ذلك ولكن انسى لن جدلا بكلامه هل
هناك في داخل الايراني مخاوف من ان تتوسع
او يتوسع نطاق الاشتباكات
حقيقه هذا السؤال مهم جدا وهو حساسيه
المنطقه
وبالتالي انا اعتقد وحسب ما فهمته من
المسؤولين الايرانيين وبشكل خاص طبعا
اولا ايران لا تريد الحرب ما افغانستان
وهي تريد ان تعيش بسلام مع من يحكم كابول
النقطه الثانيه الحركه الطلبان مستفيده
جدا من علاقاتها مع ايران وهناك الكثير من
البضائع
تحتاجها افغانستان وان كان على مستوى طاقه
النفط والبضائع الاخت اخرى شكرا
كذلك الاستاذ عبد الجداء الجبار اعذروني
على ضيق الوقت السلام عليكم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات